LORRAINE CINK: Marvel
Studios' The Falcon
and the Winter
Soldier no doubt has
some of the most high-flying
VFX in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, which is
why I wanted to talk
to VFX supervisor, Eric Leven.
Hey, Eric.
Hi, Lorraine.
LORRAINE CINK: Now the series
has some incredible action
sequences.
What was your overall
vision for those action
sequences in the show?
ERIC LEVEN: What I really
wanted to do for the big action
sequences was, as
much as possible,
make things feel like
they're grounded in reality.
So obviously, we don't have
Anthony Mackie flying around
in a real jetpack
with real wings,
but we want to make it
feel like, if he was,
how would we film that?
There are people who
can actually fly.
You have wingsuit pilots
who jump out of airplanes.
They all have little
helmet cameras.
Kari Skogland, the
director, really
wanted to bring that
language to our show as well.
So we actually have many shots
where we've got an action cam
in front of Sam's face, or on
the wingtip, and as he moves,
we see the entire world
move around him and things
like that.
And that was a really
interesting, new
visual language to
bring to the show
that we haven't brought before.
I think that new visual
language is really clear,
especially when you
look at other MCU
characters who also fly.
But what makes Falcon's
flight so unique?
ERIC LEVEN: It was
important for us
to have Falcon feel like
a different character.
There are so many other
characters in the MCU
that fly, like Iron
Man, for example.
He flies, but he has
a different center
of gravity because his
engines are in a different
place than Falcon's.
He can hover in
a way that Falcon
doesn't necessarily hover.
So we wanted to make sure
that Falcon felt different
and that we weren't sort
of copying the flight
patterns of other heroes.
Well, let's talk
about where we really
see this happening
in the show, which
is that big opening sequence.
It opens the show, so you're
sort of dropped kind of right
in the middle of it.
Sam is kind of contracting
with the Air Force.
There's a terrorist
organization out there
that is-- they think
is going to kidnap
an American Air Force plane.
And so they're sending
Sam in to go make contact
with that plane, make
sure everything's OK,
they've lost contact with it.
Then what he doesn't know,
is that these guys are
expert wingsuit pilots
and they actually
strap Captain Vassant to them
and then jump out of the plane.
So it was just sort of
this amazing moment,
like I didn't know
they could do that.
So now Sam has to chase
after these wingsuit guys.
So the first thing that we
see is Sam in the airplane,
and then he drops out backwards.
How did you create that shot?
Yeah, that was a relatively
straightforward shot.
We've seen that sort
of thing done before,
so we wanted to make sure
we put our stamp on it.
Basically, he's
in the real plane.
There are pads below him.
There's a blue screen
surrounding the plane.
And then when he falls
out of the plane,
somewhere in the
middle of that process
we basically blend to a
digital version of him.
Ideally, the effect is seamless.
You don't know where
you know Anthony starts
and where the digital
version begins.
That sequence is so wild.
You really can't
tell what's real
and what was shot practically.
How did you shoot
the scene where
Falcon lands on the plane?
Is that shot in the air?
Not with a plane in the air,
but with a plane on the ground.
That was something that we--
we previs that.
So we saw like, the sort of
video game version of it,
where we had Falcon
kind of coming
in and just sort of landing
on the plane's cockpit.
And we talked with the stunt
coordinator and the riggers
and figured out, you know, I
think we can do that for real.
We're going to be in
an Air Force base.
We have a real plane.
And they would wire
Anthony up on a traveling
harness that would actually
fly him into the shot.
And Anthony really did it.
He actually flew onto
the nose of an aircraft.
In that particular shot, I think
we've replaced him completely
at the beginning of the
shot because we didn't like
the trajectory at the
beginning, and then
we blended to real
Anthony landing
on the nose of the aircraft.
So the next crazy
thing that happens
is, there are these
wingsuit flyers
weaving between the canyons.
Did you work with
real wingsuits?
Not only are we working with
actual folks in wingsuits,
but Captain Vassant is strapped
to one of the wingsuit .
pilots.
In real life?
Yeah.
And so, that was
the sort of thing--
you know, in the story he's
strapped-- in the story,
yeah, he's going to strap him
and he's going to jump out.
And I was talking with
the stunt coordinator,
and he said, Oh, yeah,
yeah, we can do that.
What?
- What?
Oh, yeah.
No, we do it all the time.
You just strap a
guy to another guy
and he'll just
hold on real tight
and they'll jump
out of the airplane.
Any time you can do
anything for real,
you want to do it for real.
I think what's
really important in--
especially in a
sequence like this--
is even if, I don't know,
70%, 80% of the sequence
is done in a computer, it's
CG, but having enough of it
to know that it's real and
to be able to sell people,
Oh, they did that for real.
That's a real guy jumping out
of an airplane with someone
strapped to his back.
If you have enough shots
in there that are real,
I think it kind
of makes the rest
of the sequence believable.
Then you start to question
what's real, what's not,
what's digital.
And if you can't
tell, that's the goal.
And then it seems like maybe
it was all done for real.
LORRAINE CINK: The show is
action-packed from start
to finish.
And as we arrive at
the series finale,
we finally see Sam's heroic
debut as Captain America.
Could you talk us through
that big final scene?
Yeah, so everything kind of
comes to a head at the end.
And our last episode, the
Flag-Smashers have basically--
they've sort of become
radicalized at this point.
Basically, they just
take a bunch of hostages.
So one of the
Flag-Smashers takes a bunch
of hostages in a
helicopter and is flying
them all over New York City.
Then, there are two
other trucks that are
hijacked by the Flag-Smashers.
So everybody converges here.
And at one point, Karli is
just like, You know what?
I can't take this anymore.
And she's going to take one
of the trucks full of hostages
and just drive it into
a construction pit.
And it looks like the truck
is going to hit the ground,
but at the last
second, Captain America
shows up and saves the day.
I remember hearing from
Malcolm Spellman, the writer,
that he really wanted to make
this iconic moment of Sam
as Captain America saving
this truckload of people
and pushing it back to safety.
That that was really
important to him.
To have a Black
superhero do that was
really a powerful moment.
It really is such
an impactful moment.
How are you able to bring
it to life with VFX?
ERIC LEVEN: It's sort
of the same process.
Again, it starts with the page.
We'll start talking about, OK,
let's look at some storyboards.
What are the shots
going to look like?
Are these wide shots?
Are they tight shots?
If they're tight
shots, maybe we can
do it on a blue screen stage.
Can we get one of these trucks?
Can we get it in a way that
Anthony Mackie can actually
get his body into it
and get the performance
that we were looking for.
And so Special Effects
actually came in and rigged up
one of these giant
BearCats in a way
that the Mackie could actually
push against and pretend
he was pushing it up.
We start figuring
out what can be done
for real from all
the other departments
who say what they can do.
The pit itself, for
example, was shot over a--
I think it was three
story parking garage.
And three stories doesn't
seem that dangerous
when you're at the top.
You want to make sure that if
you fall in there, that there's
no chance of survival.
So we might be able to film
at this practical location,
but we might need to take
it over in visual effects
and make it seem deeper, so
we'll do some set extensions.
It's definitely an absolutely
amazing moment in the show,
but I'm curious.
Do you think there
are any moments
that people might have missed?
What folks certainly missed
is that the outfit that Captain
America wears--
he has this cowl,
that I know everybody
at Marvel was very
specific about because
it's based on the look
at the cowl in the books.
What I learned from
the costume department,
though, is that what they
want is really, really
hard to get in real life.
I don't think there
are any fabrics that
can do exactly what
they want, which
is it needs to be stretchy.
It needs to hug the
face, but it also
has to feel thick
like leather, but it
needs to flex like Spandex.
So what they end up doing
was they built something
as close as they
could possibly get it
and then depending how
Anthony turned his head,
you might get a huge
wrinkle back here.
Or the cowl might
separate from his face.
So in many, many
shots, we actually
replace that cowl so that it
would stay snug in his face
and look the way
we want it to look.
There are seams in
the back of the cowl.
And as we know, there are no
there are no seams or zippers
in the superhero
costume, so those all had
to be replaced and touched up.
There are so many details
that go into creating the VFX
for a series like
this, but what was
your absolute favorite aspect
of working on the series?
Certainly, working
with these huge action
sequences was my favorite
part of the show.
Because there's just so much
that goes into this stuff.
There's so many moving parts.
You get to work with so
many different people,
in so many different
departments,
and bringing everybody's
creativity on the table,
and working with
these amazing people
to make these action sequences
better, and better, and better,
was really, really fantastic.
Some of these
scenes, we're working
on them for over a year.
And it was just
really neat to see
them from the very
beginning all the way
through to the very end.
Wow, Eric.
It's been quite a ride.
Thank you so much
for talking to us.
And everybody, be sure to go
watch all episodes of Marvel
Studios' The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier,
now streaming on Disney Plus.